welcome back and uh we bring you uh some  breaking news this hour and it is sad  news and it is that Pele one of the  greatest uh ever footballers perhaps the  greatest uh ever footballer has passed  away in Brazil his home country uh AP  the Associated Press is reporting that  uh the Brazilian soccer Legend uh has  died at the age of 82. now Pele had been  at the Albert Einstein Hospital in Sao  Paulo receiving palliative  uh care after he stopped responding to  chemotherapy treatment for his colon  cancer  the 82 year old's daughter and other  family members have been at his side but  uh we are getting reports from the  Associated Press that the Brazilian  football legend Pele has died